اعلان هو الاول من نوعه منذ بدء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه تكشف عن تضرر
427 منزلا في المستوطنات المتاخمه للحدود
مع لبنان ثون منها اصيبت بشكل مباشر منذ
اندلاع المواجهات مع حزب الله والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في الثامن من اكتوبر الماضي
قالت الوزاره في بيان لها ان مديريه الافق
الشمالي التابعه لوزاره الدفاع تجري
تقييما للاضرار في التجمعات السكانيه على
طول الحدود الشماليه ولتنسيق جهود اعاده
التاهيل
الاوليه نعود اذا لتاريخ الثامن من اكتوبر
الماضي اسرائيل تبدا باخلاء المستوطنات
الشماليه مع لبنان تنقل صحف اسرائيليه ان
القرار اخذ على عجل بتصويت عبر الهاتف
وسيشرف وزير الدفاعي اف جالنت على
العمليه توسعت دائره الاخلاء من كيلومترين
اثنين الى خمسه كيلومترات مع تزايد التوتر
على جانبي الحدود وتكرار اقفال الطرق
الداخليه الرابطه بين هذه المستوطنات مع
كل حادث امني تسجله اسرائيل
عند حدودها الشماليه والحادث الامني تعني
به استهدافا من الجانب
الاخر كان اكثر ما تخشاه قوات الاحتلال
توغلات بريه ينفذها حزب الله او فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عبر الخط الحدودي
بطول
كيلومترا خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى قال
حزب الله انه نفذ قرابه 700 ضربه استهدفت
اكثر من
48 موقعا ونقطه عسكريه اسرائيليه بالاضافه
الى استهداف 17 مستوطنه على
الحدود ادت الى فرار قرابه 50 الف مستوطن
لم يعودوا بعد اسكنته الحكومه في فنادق
بداخل
اسرائيل مع نهايه يناير من العام الحالي
قالت يديعوت احرونوت ان الجيش قلص عدد
الجنود المتمركزين في المناطق القريبه مع
لبنان وخفض عدد قواته المنتشره ونقلت
الصحيفه ان تامين المستوطنات سيكون مهمه
فرق الانذار المحليه وسيطلب منها
الاستجابه للتهديدات الامنيه لحين وصول
اليش متى وان استدعى الامر ذلك اعلان وقع
كالصاعقه على ما تسمى فرق الانذار المحليه
انتقد قادتها قرار الجيش وقالوا انهم لم
يعلموا عنه الا قبل ايام من تنفيذه ونقلت
الصحيفه عم من سمته قائد فرقه تاهب قرب
الحدود اللبنانيه
قوله لقد وعدوا بحمايتنا بعد الحرب في غزه
لكننا لم نتصور ان
يتركونا والحرب لا تزال
مستمره